Speaker 1: The other part I want to talk about
of Joe Biden's press conference yesterday.
Remember Joe Biden criticized by the right
for not doing a press conference for a while?
Did one yesterday and took questions for nearly
two hours, and some right wingers were saying
he went on too long.
The Drudge Report had a splash headline about
marathon press conference.
He doesn't do one and you criticize him, and
then he he answers too many questions and
then you criticize.
Give me a break, guys.
One person who was extraordinarily triggered
by Joe Biden's press conference yesterday,
and I think it's both what was in the press
conference and the fact that it's Joe Biden
doing a press conference rather than him is
Donald Trump.
Donald Trump putting out a statement yesterday
through his Save America thing and what he
said was how come Biden picks a reporter off
a list in all cases, softball questions and
then reads the answer.
I would never have been allowed to get away
with that, nor would I have do then.
Donald Trump appearing with Fox News host
and radio host.
I don't remember if it's Westwood One or where
Mark Levin hosts his show.
Right wing host Mark Levin.
And Trump is just completely triggered by
the fact that people paid attention to Joe
Biden.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 4: I noticed I noticed a lot of things.
I noticed things that are affecting the American
people directly.
He thinks things are going pretty swimmingly.
They didn't talk about crime.
They didn't talk about what's going on in
the classroom.
They didn't talk about what's happening at
the border.
And he was there for almost two hours, and
none of that came up.
Don't you find that remarkable?
Well, crime is so bad.
It's so out of control when you look at these
kids being shoved off subway stations in New
York, off platforms right into a train.
Now that
Speaker 1: that's horrible.
What on earth does that have to do with Joe
Biden?
That it's it's we're talking about NYPD, like
why are they on the one hand, they say, let
states and municipalities do what's right
for them.
But it's Joe Biden's fault that something
is happening on the subways of New York.
It's tragic.
But what does it have to do with Joe
Speaker 4: Biden in full speed and a young
woman's thrown right into the train, right
into the face?
Speaker 1: So as you can hear, by the way,
this is down or Trump right now, very, very
down low energy.
Speaker 4: The train killed instantly.
And then you look at what happened with the
young lady selling in a furniture store selling
furniture and somebody walks in a knife.
Sort of death.
Horrible.
And nothing happens to these people.
Nothing happens.
Speaker 1: And the other question here, of
course, when we talk about violence in cities
is they talk about dangerous democratic democratic
run cities.
As many of you know, because I've done this
so many times, most cities are done by Democrats,
run by Democrats, because more Democrats want
to live in cities and Republicans tend to
live more rurally.
So really safe cities are run by Democrats,
and higher crime cities are run by Democrats
because cities tend to be run by Democrats.
OK, let's continue.
Trump angry with the reporters during the
press conference,
Speaker 4: a commander in chief saying that
he expects Russia to invade Ukraine.
Now, don't you think Vladimir Putin heard
that too?
Well, yeah.
And it was like, the problem is, it was like,
nothing's going to be done, you know, and
say, Yeah, I expect him now.
Maybe it was a mistake because it was set
in the middle of another sentence and another
thought.
But he said, use the words expects that he's
going in.
And I thought that was strange.
What do you don't want it to happen or did
you know?
I just thought it was a very strange thought
to be putting out there that he what
Speaker 1: great analysis from Trump
Speaker 4: asks him to go.
And a nobody seems to pick it up because the
reporters are the most friendly group of reporters
I've ever seen didn't even ask questions.
They make positive statements and then sit
down.
Speaker 1: You know, I really didn't see it
that way.
We, I, we have I have been endlessly critical
of of of the press corps when Trump was president
and when Biden is president.
I think there are often things managed by
the press corps in ways that I think don't
really make sense.
But that was not what took.
Place yesterday, there were real questions
asked of Joe Biden.
Biden sometimes didn't even answer them.
Biden was asked straight up what happened
to canceling 10 grand in student debt.
He literally never answered the question he
walked off.
Wasn't wasn't pressed on it.
So I've made criticisms of Biden of report,
but it was not a friendly press conference
in the way Trump is describing here whatsoever.
Here's more of Trump on the press conference.
Speaker 4: Patriots it's a great honor to
have.
Speaker 1: This is from the start of the interview.
Speaker 4: President Donald Trump, President
Trump.
How are you, sir?
Sir, hello, mark.
How are you?
I'm doing great.
President Trump, I imagine you saw most of
this press conference and I did.
And Joe Biden said he's had enormous progress
during his presidency.
I don't see it that way to you.
Well, progress in destroying our country.
Yes, I think that's been tremendous.
He also said something that I assume was a
mistake, but he said he expects Putin to go
in.
He said I expect him to go in to go into Ukraine,
and I thought that was a very unusual answer.
I don't know if he knew what he was saying
because it was, he said that as part of another
question, it was a little confused because
he tried to correct something.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's part of the Biden
dementia narrative, which Trump continues
to push.
And then, of course, at some point it must
be mentioned that Joe Biden is pushing us
towards communism.
And that did come up, of course, as absurd
as it is.
Speaker 4: Mm-Hmm.
You know, Joe Biden says he's not moved to
the left produce, he said doing it, why are
you trying to take the country to the left?
He says, I'm a moderate, I'm not a socialist.
I'm not Bernie Sanders.
I think his actions defy that, don't they?
Well, he says all that.
He said that during the debates, he said that
during his debates with other Democrats and
of
Speaker 1: course, it's true Joe Biden has
not moved us towards socialism or communism,
and I would encourage anybody who believes
that he has to explain exactly which policies
have done so.
Speaker 4: But it's not true.
And you know what he said on energy?
You look at what he said on energy, look at
what do you take a look at religion, what's
going on there?
You nothing.
You know, the stances that these Democrats?
I mean,
Speaker 1: quite literally, nothing is going
on
Speaker 4: the radical left Democrats are
taking no, he said.
All of these things that that we're a very
moderate.
And then he did things that nobody could believe.
Bernie Sanders cannot believe what's happening.
Speaker 1: He said, Yes, Bernie is like, Oh
my god, Joe, you're so far left.
I can't believe it.
Speaker 4: I would have never gotten away
with any of this stuff.
It's it's not.
It's not really even believable what's happening
to me.
Speaker 1: So Trump audibly confused.
And again, look at Biden's actions.
Tell me which ones are the socialist communist
ones?
He did COVID stimulus, but Trump did two of
them.
He rolled out the vaccine that Republicans
believe Trump made.
That's not very far left.
He passed a very modest infrastructure bill
and he got out of Afghanistan, which was Trump's
plan.
So if any time anybody says to you, remember
when Jesse Lee Peterson interviewed me in
L.A. when Obama was president, he or no, I
think no Trump was president, but it was about
what Barack Obama did.
He said Obama was a socialist and I was like,
Well, what did he do?
And he's like, Well, he gave some people cell
phones.
That was Jesse Lee Peterson explanation.
So when people say Biden is going socialist,
communist asked specifically, which policies
are the socialistic communistic policies?
I'm curious to see what people tell you.